العراق بلغاريا ماليزيا مصر حيث اغتيل
الملحق الاداري بالسفاره المصريه تشاد
الكونغو قطر ويوغندا بل واكثر من ذلك
تمثلت في اطلاق الاعين الناريه على مقرات
البعثات والسفراء وسرقت سياراتهم او
تهشيمها وتحطيم كاميرات المراقبه وتمركز
قوات التمرد حولها مباشره لاحداث الرعب
واستهداف كرفانات الحمايه هناك جرائم
ارتكبت ضد المؤسسات الحكوميه على النحو
التالي سرقه سجلات المحاكم والهيئه
القضائيه تدمير وسرقه سجلات الاراضي في
مصلحه الاراضي وهذا يهدف الى انهاء وثائق
ملكيه المساكن التي احتلتها الميليشيا في
احياء سكنيه وقع عليها الاختيار بعنايه
هناك جرائم يمكن ادراجها تحت مسمى التجريف
الثقافي والتاريخي نهب متحف الهيئه
القضائيه تدمير المتحف العسكري تهديم
المتحف القومي وتخريب الجامعات مثل جامعه
الاحفاد الشهيره جامعه ام درمان الاهليه
وجامعات اخرى تم تدمير بعض الاثار
التاريخيه في ام درمان العاصمه الوطنيه
وهناك جرائم الاعتداء على الشرف واغتصاب
الحرائر بدوافع لا تخلو من اشاره الشرف
العائلي وقدش العفو والحياه بجانب جرائم
احتجازا المدنيين بمن فيهما النساء
والاطفال واتلاف ملايين الجرعات الخاصه
بتطعيم الاطفال بالاضافه الى ذلك فقد تم
استهداف واقتحام المساجد وخمس كنائس
والاعيان المدنيه وتحويلها الى مقرات
عسكريه وفي هذا الاطار نشير الى تصريح
الاستاذ السليمه اسحاق مدير وحده مكافحه
العنف ضد المراه بشان التحقيق في حالات
الاغتصاب التي ارتكبتها المليشيا المتمرده
السيد الرئيسه الا يعتبر مجلس الامن
الموقر هذه الانتهاكات الممنهجه بمثابه
ارتكاب جريمه العدوان الشامل وتدوير عاصمه
البلاد وغيرها من الدوائر الحاضريه وتخريب
الطرق القوميه والمطارات والبنيات التحتيه
المنشات الاستراتيجيه والحيويه بهدف خلق
حاله من الزعل والفوضى تؤدي الى انهيار
الدوله ولذلك يطلب السودان ادانه المجتمع
الدولي ومجلس الامن باقوى العبارات هذا
العدوان والمخطط غير المسبوق وارتكاب
الجرائم ضد الدوله والبعثات الدبلوماسيه
والمنظمات الدوليه السيدات والساده فيما
يخص بناء السلامه الاهلي بمميزات الجهود
الرسميه التي بذلتها يونيون والتي تبذلها
ايضا حكومه السودان هناك جهود اهليه واخرى
تقوم بها منظمات المجتمع المدني من اجل
بناء السلام المدني وتفعيل التراضي
المجتمعي في هذا الاطار وقعت المكونات
المدنيه بولايه جنوب دارفور وثيقه عقد
اجتماعي وتراضي مجتمعي ضمه 80 قبيله
بالولايات حيث ذكر بعض الوفود ان هناك اثر
اثني يتفاقم وذلك لتطويق ما ذكرتموه وذلك
ضمن جهود المبادره المجتمعيه بال ولايه
الوقف الحرب واستعاده الحياه المدنيه
ولمعالجه الاوضاع بمدينه جنينه وولايه غرب
دارفور انعقد اجتماع طارئ ضم حاكم اقليم
دارفور مع ولايه ولايات دارفور
حيث تقرر قيام الولاه برئاسه حاكم الاقليم
بزياره عاجله الى الجنينه حاضره ولايه غرب
دارفور بصحبه متطوعين من الاطقم الطبيه
والادارات الاهليه والمنظمات الوطنيه
والمبادرون للوقوف ميدانيا على الاوضاع
الامنيه والانسانيه والعمل مع السلطات
الولايه لنزع فتيل الازمه واستدباب الامن
وتحقيق السلام بعد الاحداث الدمويه التي
شهدتها الولايه على مدار الايام الماضيه
كما تم ارسال الادويه والمواد الايوائيه
الموجوده في بورسودان عبر مطريه الفاشر
ونيال لتوزيعها على المتضررين اضافه الى
تامين كل الطرق الداخليه والقوميه من والى
دارفور السيد الرئيسه فيما يخص التداعيات
الاقليميه السلبيه التي ذكرتها بعض الوفود
هناك التباس مفاهيمي يتعلق بتوصيف
السودانيين الذين وفدوا الى بعض دول
الجوار في الايام الماضيه باستخدام
مصطلحات لاجئين ومشردين داخلين على النحو
وهذا الدفع ليس للانكار بل لتجليه الحقائق
اللاجئ في اتفاقيه طعام 51 يعني شخص خارج
البلد الذي يحمل جنسيته غير قادر بسبب خوف
مبرر من التعرض للالتهاب لاسباب تتعلق
بالعرق او الدين او الجنسيه او الانتباه
الى اجتماعيه معينه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات